Fitness is a unassuming yet powerful
vehicle for personal growth you know you
show up it hurts it's hard you fail
you'll learn you practice you learn body
acceptance even though most people
initially start exercising because of
maybe some insecurities about their body
if you do it long enough you really
start to accept like this is this is my
body this is how I look and Beauty being
Aesthetics how you look contributes very
very little to happiness so he says like
let's say you're on a scale of one to
ten you're a six and you spend all kinds
of time money and effort to plastic
surgery whatever to look to get yourself
up to a nine because your happiness will
go up a tiny tiny fraction not the case
with Fitness it's the journey in the
process showing up it's hard it's
acceptance It's changing your
relationship to pain boy is that carry
over to uh everyday life we had a magic
pill that gave you all of the benefits
it's like taking a helicopter ride to
the top of Mount Everest beautiful view
is it the same thing as climbing the
mountains it's not even close you can't
compare the two